not only does the First Amendment not
kick religion out of public life it
doesn't even prohibit the establishment
of a state Church the reason that the
First Amendment Establishment Clause
prohibits a church established at the
national level is because there already
were established churches at the state
level that went on unmolested for
decades in our proclamations even from
the religiously slightly wobbly founding
fathers men like Benjamin Franklin they
all gave thanks to God John Adams made
clear that the morality also in a
private letter that the morality for
America ought to be the Christian
morality that that was the one suited to
it John Jay gave great thanks that we
were a Christian Nation of practicing
Christians Who had who had a long
history with one another we have in God
we trust on our currency it's in our
national anthem actually in the not very
often sung fifth verse it would seem to
me that the pr- religion in public life
side has has the winning argument here